so let's see a black game black blitz
game and 1.e4 so let's play French and
see what happens in 83 I want to try a
line that i recently saw in a game and
this is the line so 27 or b6 very
similar the idea is to exchange with
bishop asics the the light squared
Bishop and play a very close game here
obviously it doesn't want me to exchange
and go sir before can I place his six
and Bishop basics I'll try that on
bishop asics instantly but he can play
b5 aha so we insist insists on on this
IDM interesting okay let's go push your
basics on b5 a player should be seven
and then I'm not sure maybe he needs to
take or play a flag if he doesn't take
on c6 now which really doesn't look too
too threatening for black um if he
doesn't take then I have for the c5 idea
yeah c5 means that um of course my
bishop would stay I will stay bad but I
have fun pretty good play in the center
potential ideas on the on the C file
for example I could think about taking
now and Bishop to c5 okay but let's um
think about this for a moment the
problem he also is my really bad
development um and sometimes he might
play at five so I must be careful with
them with this position okay maybe let's
let's play this first I'm threatening to
take on d4 which GM obviously doesn't
regard as a threat I mean okay after
taking you can go to e to some this is
some understand the one somewhere f5 is
this a threat no maybe okay maybe I need
to spend even one more porn move to to
take care about this take care of this
not about um yeah it's um it looks a bit
shaky with the lots of pawn moves and
moving pieces twice and even more hmm
yeah maybe he am he's really intending
to play G form as possible but then I
mean g45 really weakens eff okay okay so
very direct play so what does the idea
9h fire Queen to Queen to h5 and then
naughty six or something if I take on d4
know what what's the answer Queen age
five
I take on e5 then you can take on e6 mm
okay what if i go ninety seven and 96 I
mean absolutely this is this is not
working what is what is playing here
pretty sure about that I mean the
position that I that has set up is a bit
shaky but I don't think that this this
is the way to go about that i mean i can
i'm just 11 moves away from oops not not
not a pre move please I'm just one move
away from from long castle and I don't
see em how long he prevents that his
center is completely collapsing now with
see takes d4 Knight xe5 and so on yeah
now I intended night to to g6 to cover
this okay you can try I don't know
Bishop f5 or something Bishop f5 he
takes f-5e six ok ok so maybe may be
dangerous so pricilla but he needs to do
something like that I mean you cannot as
i don't think it can afford some slow
move yeah this is another possible
sacrifice so the rook is singing if i
take here Bishop f5 ok takes roop takes
King back ok whatever I need to take
if I take yeah you can take you can play
six maybe but at son Philip J if it
takes with the Queen I go to e8 and it's
just one check I don't know let's grab
this I cannot decline the the SEC anyway
so let's go here yeah I don't have so
much time left I think this is more more
of an issue than the position really
it's of course it's practice it's
dangerous and a practical game but I
don't think widest what is really
winning Bishop g5 I can play Bishop e7
Queen f7 ok as an only move 26 just
Bishop e7 I don't know I have fun lots
of pieces near my king some is sexy can
try but ok at least I don't need to
think about this the reply who came the
prom they need to take may be here to
have queen bee seven queen bee seven now
don't don't have time to really
think about alternatives much but one
one thing is clear I mean then I with
two pieces up so I can I can return one
piece and it's still it's still not not
a big deal maybe this wasn't even
necessary quincy 7y am 30 seconds yeah
20 seconds look everyone i can take care
don't see me some believable
yeah it wasn't easy hmm you know in a
practical game I'm type of course black
boss just completely winning here just
entire day I should I should manage
really 30 seconds is enough on Adams
here I can just take 22 yeah and after
the second resigning from text you too
there about 20 seconds here queenie
queenie tues winning ok ok on g2 made on
g 2 i'm an idiot idiotic 20 seconds this
is even easy and it protects e7 yeah
this um this is really easy just Queenie
to him yeah I didn't see a move here
when you two didn't come to my mind yeah
and and over I can we can give a check
and I just go here let's see i have an
extra piece i mean just just the night
is extra here you gave her way to pawn
so at some just 11 piece extra
yeah okay this attacker wasn't really
working for white but I spent too much
time so I'm typical blitz blitz thing
yeah thanks for watching interesting it
was for certain